Okay. It is time for hate treat male. What
is hatred that male, this is Patriot mail.
So what if the president's been accused of
sexual Harrison 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star? At least he never wore
a tan suit. Patriot written by patriots. Who
Haig? David Pakman because America and because
freedom.
That's right. Patriot mail is when a professional
voiceover artist interprets the hate mail
that I get a and there is a lot of interpretation
to be done with this week's hatred mail. Take
a listen to it,
David Park, man, liar, liar, liar, liar, liar,
liar. You are very sick and disgusting. David
Parkman shame on you. The week of pathologists
to Ju total Beta pansy. What a shameful. How
are David, you shame the name David wine and
play the victim Beda
yeah. This whole Beta thing has really, um,
uh, picked up and I actually don't know when
it started exactly like did Beta, I, I don't
think it stemmed from the Trump presidency,
although I think it was significantly popularized.
I think the whole Alpha male Beta male thing,
um, has maybe surfaced in the same vein as
the sort of soy boy ad hominems of the left.
But I don't even, maybe men's rights activism
has a role to play in this whole Alpha Beta
thing. Uh, but it's all incredibly stupid
and wildly immature, which makes it perfect
for hatreds. Send a middle finger salute to
the hatreds by becoming a member on our website
and using the coupon code hatred at 40 okay.
The coupon code hatred 40 which I'll spell
for you in a moment, saves you 40% off of
any membership and it's a direct signal.
It's a message to the hatred hatreds that
they can use whatever homophobic slurs they
want in their messages. To me, they can use
whatever antisemitic slurs they want. They
can use whatever a NASCAR elating terms they
think will trigger me that they want. You
are not going to be bullied and you are actually
going to say, I support progressive independent
media like the David Pakman show and using
the coupon code hatred at 40 when you become
a member sends exactly that message. The coupon
code is spelled h t r I o t four zero and
it'll save you 40% and make many hatreds cry
at the impotence of their attacks on me.